I do believe parties can take two months
of planning you know to get them to run
its aside for olay yeah I'd love to be
in last night so let me create a cupcake
so the other thing like me don't bring
those own and I made a reg cake so it's
like a chocolate Texas sheet cake event
that's a skin Bowl initial sorry G
Robert Emilio Daniel so we call it the
red cake yeah I only do this once a year
all the machines on benefit each of the
breakers I've actually put about 20
acres
they worked last year with ten machines
now about thirteen but we should be okay
pinball tournaments are really
challenging to win you have to know how
to play on all style of games from old
to new to mid age remember plaintiff
when I was like five years old almost in
kindergarten it was just so much fun I
like the music the lights everything
can almost combine it all together kind
thing I think you have a natural passion
for started fitting if you want to get
good at something you have to feel that
passion in you
it feels amazing when you can just hit
everything you want to me I call that
being in the zone I think of nothing but
being in that zone don't think of
anything else at all it's one of the
most amazing feelings in the world
actually you feel a little happy inside
[Music]
I think I was meant to play involved
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Robert was born almost exactly two years
after my oldest child and I felt really
good but he was kind of a floppy baby
like he used to like just spin
everything it's been himself it's been
objects if something wasn't spinning
he'd make it spin he gravitate to like
exit signs and try to reach exit signs
and buttons and light switches and stuff
like you wouldn't buy the video that
twice he was always going for all these
mechanical things so all these kind of
red flags were at the back of my head
but he was also a very very cute baby he
looks so good people said oh you know
lots of boys don't talk like four or
five so I used to think maybe I'm just
over imagining things or over analyzing
things he eventually got by the time he
was three he got diagnosed with autism
and a mild mental handicap and we were
told he may never learn to talk or read
right I went to Gladstone High School in
East Vancouver and I'd always go to
Wally burgers and I took Robert there
just for the hamburger I love to have a
reason I thought he'd like him to it I
think was about five years old
and it was a game in the corner Twilight
Zone and he got on this soapbox and he
started flipping away those foot
present' I I think that was really the
first time he ever played pinball four
or five years old and
then after that he is hooked on them
[Music]
daddy's on
[Music]
you might feel like well on a pinball -
I can't like Guns N'Roses
one time dead in the US and this is
feeling like a concert - it almost was
involved like I feel like I live on the
road away from home a lot a year it
seems this probably like 30 weeks of
weekends with pinball competing which is
quite a lot during the air I want to
become a legend like Quito one dead in
the stage we have the most complete flip
the work of that when is minie balls
going on why he can think like he adapts
Andreea is the wildtype to me under the
dream is like complete on the fly yet
amazingly accurate I like that guy Haley
George is a well-researched a player
medially are the two highest ranked
plays in the Pacific Northwest together
Andy Rosa I like him for his hairstyle
and he Rosa I said one of the best
nudges out there like his reaction time
is incredible Jurgen has complete
flipper skills and accuracy he's a very
serious player and a see a very skilled
poker player back in this country Elena
Walters on the guest rooms are ramps and
also shooting neural shots until I won
the only women ranked in the top hundred
and low ranking
when he first started off like it was
like a lot of social coaching my
collaborative oh shake the hair every to
say congratulations hours work on being
a good loser but also a good winner
sometimes I can feel over stimulating
kind of thing because it's like so much
information my brain has a process but I
want to be treated just as a typical
individual who doesn't have autism I
went to my final game congratulations
that's awesome
one of the features of many people with
autism is that when they're interested
in something they're really interested
in something something they learned the
rules they like to read about it um if
it's something they can practice know
they'll practice and so like he does
have that as well a probably place work
involving most people as well I think he
does have other interests but that group
of people they don't mind talking that
length the boat pinball normal Tom I
knew details of pinball because they
kind of get that too like they're just
as interested in pinball as he is I
think he likes that like I think he
likes the fact that a lot of players
look up to him are they asking for
advice because of how good he is
they appreciate Robert and Robert
probably feels a lot more at ease with
them as well
[Music]
people will respect you for who you are
if you just behave good and have a good
attitude obviously obviously better in
order to come by class I'm tired
Anna chooses what people seem to always
remember bets
I would love to teens were ranked number
one when they involved that's really
quite a ways dill or divine be number
one in the world and anything that's a
long work in progress right now but you
can't really get anything you want just
from standing there
you can't expect you to this fall from
the sky or something
it takes a lot of determination passion
and just really really wanting this so
much that you'll do everything in your
power possible to get it
we have to keep that discipline no
matter how frustrating and how slow is
going to feel to you we all have to
slowly build our way up right to the end
you
[Music]